happy Saturday reject nation I'm Greg
Alba John hump we're gonna watch the
trailer for fantastic beasts in the
crimes of Grindelwald oh boy
from comic-con 2018 well I'm excited for
this because you know I kind of remember
the first one Hey patron of the day
shout out want to give it to a Delia
Chamberland today I was talking with the
Delia she's one of our longtime patrons
and she was telling you about this
unique type of condition
it's called hypergraphia I don't know if
she's okay with me talking about it but
I want to talk about it's a behavioral
condition classified by an intense urge
to write damn which is the coolest
condition I could have ever heard of you
can make a movie like that where it's a
superpower and considering that you know
this comes from a famous author JK
Rowling I wanted to shout you out today
because she's written in several books
and she wants to one day publish one of
them and I highly encourage you to keep
going out there keep writing and publish
one of your novels and in fact you could
send us one of your books and I think
you're planning on doing that and we
will take about two years to read it
knowing the pace that John and I read at
and then we'll hop right to it okay my
dear and then we'll make her an audio
book out of it cuz that's what you've
always wanted right yeah let's reading
your words
well Adelia we love you it's time to
watch this trailer just found out zoe
kravitz was asked what they would use
magic for she said impeach trump I'd
stand with her let's watch this
I'm scared Professor Dumbledore
Dumbledore everyone ridiculous Jim
boggarts again Euronext he does an
unusual one what mr. Scamander fears
above everything else is having to work
in an office that's ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]
after the rumors in efficient that he
would rise to dominance over the
Wizarding World
he will the Alaska media world hunting
down the lady of the travelers castle
I can't move against in the vault
it has to be here in your shoes I'd
probably refuse to there's late evening
it
you underestimate your talents misters
come on how this works that's crazy
muggles are not lesser
Oh
you couldn't eat you never met a monster
you couldn't
[Music]
oh my god Dumbledore for you
[Music]
why are you know I'm alive
what I'm an alchemist them therefore
immortal oh you're gonna oh damn oh you
don't look a day over 375 alright so
between the two of us John is definitely
you know the Harry Potter fan I've seen
all the Harry Potter movies but you've
read all the books I have read all the
books it's right that makes me a better
fan than you yeah
the thing with prequels is it's hard for
me to really feel the stakes
sometimes yeah because they're kind of
giving this really doom and gloom vibe
here well there's only real I know he's
not gonna win at the end of this
franchise Johnny Depp has a very strange
image in everyone's eyes these days we
talked about him quite a bit on this
channel John said it best at a live
event he's like a pumpkin yeah I know
there's been quite a backlash for them
being in it and there's a lot of him in
this trailer and you kind of have to it
I don't use the title character I feel
like we can maybe adjust to being on
board a little bit more for him being in
it because of the fact that he's the bad
guy that's usually the scapegoat as a
bad public image is you just make them a
bad guy movie then we could get on board
for it it's okay cuz we get to
cathartica Lee hate them on yeah he's
doing you know the Johnny Depp British
accent that we all heard a billion
faster he looks like he's doing a good
job I'll give him that looks like it
looks permitted he looks committed which
I'm happy for the highlights for me in
here would have to actually be Jude
Law's Dumbledore that was the biggest
takeaway he looks like such a great
charm in charisma yeah he captures that
warm sparkly Dumbledore glow where
you're like this guy clearly knows what
he's doing but I just feel so at ease
and warm in your presence you know and
especially that scene with the Defense
Against the Dark Arts class where
they're doing the Boggart thing and
seeing him young
like I'm actually excited for that stuff
yeah the stakes look a lot higher and
the emotional intensity seems a lot more
raised which is making me want to go
back and revisit the first one again
yeah because I'm like I want to be as
invested in this one as possible because
this looks epic this looks grand yeah
the first one had a different set of
stakes were these creatures are you go
yeah back in the bag yeah this one's
like oh life and death real-world stakes
and stuff well it looks like it's
starting off in our realm of cool
fantasy then it's gonna get
progressively darker I don't know how
people are responding to that moment
where giant ups kind of like on this
chariot of what are those Ragan's or
horses I'm not gonna make it out I think
they're thestrals which are these like
skeleton horses with wings if I'm not
okay
I mean it looks a little cheesy but it
looks cool cheesy to me it looks very
fantastical oh yeah which I do
appreciate a lot from this trailer is
just the fantastical quality overall I
mean you've got that like circus vibe
you've got people operating evaporating
all over the place for this franchise
I'm curious to see how natural it's
gonna feel to have new taking on this
you know threat because that's just not
the purpose of that character as I
perceived it originally but this
definitely looks a lot more epic and a
lot bigger in the scope of story yeah
and there seems to be even more
characters now that it doesn't even feel
like Newt central focused yeah this
feels like an unsound like little kiss a
bit under barely in the tree little Newt
and Dumbledore and Grindelwald and a
little bit of Eddie Redmayne but for
what it is I mean this was an epic
trailer and I'm actually really looking
forward to it I really am I kind of
appreciate that we didn't see Hogwarts
in the first one and now we're really
diving more back into it yeah one of all
these different ways to keep a franchise
alive you know I didn't think the first
fantastic piece was amazing but I did
think it was pretty good enough that I
still remember it it's still stuck with
me in the Harry Potter worlds aura is
one I do dearly yes yeah alright guys
well what did you think of the fantastic
beasts and the crimes of Grindelwald
trailer can you see past the depth stir
I know the male demographic can on this
channel we want you princess alright
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Val you
can check us out on patreon where we do
full-length TV show reactions weekly q
and A's and music video coverage would
love to have you become a patronage act
today